i think it's part of who we are as a
species to ask the question of where are
we where did we come from where are we
going and are we going there alone
[Music]
the largest mirrors in the world enable
a chance for all of us to answer those
questions that mean so much to us
[Music]
my name is patrick mccarthy and i'm the
principal astronomer behind the giant
magellan telescope project the largest
telescope in the world
handcrafted start to finish here at the
university of arizona
the process of making a mirror
in some sense it's like making a cake
first thing is you get all the
ingredients we have the glass
we build the mold and we put the glass
on top
and then you put it in the oven
[Music]
it's then heated up to such a high
temperature that the glass melts until
it follows into the mold and makes the
rough shape of your cake now in our case
the icing is the hard part
the mirrors weigh about 17 tons they're
up to 8.4 meters in diameter that's a
really big piece of glass
then to turn that piece of glass into a
final optics takes another two to three
years of precision grinding and
polishing and testing
each mirror from start to finish takes
roughly seven years to produce and
there's roughly 100 people working on it
so about 200 person years that go into
making one of these bears
the giant magellan telescope will be
cited in the chilean andes have the
sharpest images in chile dry weather
clear skies and no artificial lights
it's a perfect place for astronomy
the challenge of course is how you
handle this beautiful precision piece of
glass and so we lift it with suction
cups
the mirrors are moved very carefully
because they are glass after all
[Music]
telescopes are our vehicles of discovery
there are ships in the universe and the
heart of the telescope is the mirror
it's a thing that collects the light
that's come from millions or billions of
light years away and brings us that
information that can allow us to answer
those questions
where did we come from where are we
going are we alone
you